do you do you support the man who had
the woman's lingerie in Gaza a woman
who's probably killed I'm not having a
debate with you you're just going to
just me just me just me and you let's we
talk me and you me and
you do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad Arad Muhammad Arad has helped
develop allot of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this
course to access the free life-changing
training now why did you have a problem
with me going to a charity who's
inviting a war criminal who had woman's
one second one second do you do you
support the man who had the woman's
lingerie in Gaza a woman who's probably
killed I'm I'm not having a debate with
you you're just going to frame anywhere
you want and you're going up to no no
you're going up to me you're a coward
I'm not doing this weird thing no I'm
not doing you're going up to me okay
okay you came to me you came to me yeah
no listen listen I know I know
look you're coward walk away come here
you're coward coward you're a coward
you're a coward you're a coward he
supports the man the IDE of soldier who
was holding the Muslim woman's lingerie
in Gaza she was probably dead and this
scumbag coming to my face oh I support
the IDF and walking away like like
you're going to get away with it brother
I was doing my own also go to go go pray
he comes to my face and goes you're a
coward you're a coward you're a coward
you should go to jail you coward you
coward come I now second come why why
why why are you run away You're a coward
you're a coward you're a coward you're a
coward you're a coward it's just me just
me just me and you let's no talk me and
you me and you me and you me and you you
IDF baby killer you're a baby killer
you're a baby killer you're a baby
killer scumbag scumbag there you
[Music]
goard shut the hell up man what the hell
you talking
about thaty love you one second one
second second why am I following do you
know do you know why I'm following him
huh do you know why I'm following him I
don't know shut the hell up shut the
hell up bro why you following
him that's a peaceful thing to do to
follow somebody to harass them see look
look he goes why you following him I go
do you know why I'm following he goes no
shut the hell up brother the guy is
coming to my face and defending IDF who
are killing babies do you support that
do I support what killing babies in Gaza
I don't don't thank you then go chase
him go chase what I'm he's come to me
Pro defending somebody who's killed
innocent people and I'm there
confronting you're telling me why I'm so
do you supp
ham bro this guy's a joker
bro alhamdulillah bro alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah aldah alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah going to cut
the video your AG die in your ra die in
your R listen listen listen you finish
my flipping intellectual
he came to me right I right
here
likeus
stoping you still have alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah in your ra and I would
answer and I'm I condemn anyone that
don't pray namas how about that so in a
nutsh guys I was I was minding my own
business I was about to go and pray this
the guy who was who I was chasing or not
chasing following he comes to me and
goes oh why you support why you um
harassing the boys club or whatever it's
called yeah okay the boys club yeah IDF
and he goes I support IDF bro how you
going to come to my face and say to me
you support an IDF and then like a
coward run away R and then run away so I
said said bro come here where you going
let's talk let's talk cuz he was coming
to me like he's going to do something I
said what you going to do and then I
realized he's a little wimp yeah he just
here to talk then afterwards you know
who he's defending he's defending the
scumback the dirt back IDE of soldier
who went to Gaza and in Gaza a sister
who's probably been killed he's holding
her lingerie and mocking her ha and this
scum back excuse my language forgive me
they are bastards I don't care what
anyone says he's going to come to my
faith and say I support IDF and when I
Tred to confront him he runs around it
runs away like a little weasel so to me
it's very simple I was minding my
business he comes to my faith I support
IDF we try to confront him and challenge
him and he runs off like a carrot a
coward a carrot as well actually he's a
carrot as well he's a carrot he a coward
carrot trying to get